i agree with you that money is corrupted
politics um i think citizens united was
a terrible ruling it made a bad
situation worse
um i have a proposal that i think would
help um so certainly i'm for overturning
citizens united but practically that's
next to impossible because it would
require a super majority possibly even a
constitutional amendment well if you had
a constitutional amendment that would uh
limit the amount of money that could be
put in the campaigns
and you could limit the amount of time
people spent campaigning it would make
progress uh but it's not likely to
happen in singapore for example uh the
prime minister and i talked to him last
time he said he just campaigned and how
how long was your campaign four days the
campaign for prime minister or the the
parliament was about four days maybe it
was a week
our campaigns are basically
never ending right
and the amount of money is extraordinary
that's spent in it and as you probably
know from your own experience where does
most of the money go
a large part of it goes to media
and it's a it's an incredible uh you
know sinkhole advertising and media
social media is where the money mostly
goes now yeah it's even more of a
sinkhole when you think about the fact
that billions are spent in opposition to
each other essentially cancelling each
other out i mean uh if the rnc and the
dnc were to just jointly look at each
other and say hey i'll take a billion
you take a billion and maybe we
uh fix some roads
or do something that the country would
benefit from so i don't i don't know how
much now in the in the most world most
parts of the campaign world you would
know this as a candidate
people volunteer
and people uh work for very low wages
but in the media buying part and the
advertising part of part of campaigns
the people that actually buy it they get
a percentage of the revenue that you're
spending
and that's an incredible incentive for
people to get in in the business of of
getting people like you to spend more
money on advertising because they're
getting a percentage of the revenue
[Music]
if you were a patriotic billionaire what
would you do this week my interview with
world class investor and philanthropist
coiner of the term patriotic
philanthropy david rubinstein david also
recently authored a book the american
experiment dialogues on a dream that
consists of interviews with thinkers and
historians about
america's history and what lies ahead
this week on forward
[Music]
it is my pleasure and privilege to
welcome to the podcast world-class
investor philanthropist now
multiple-time best-selling author and
interviewer david rubinstein david
welcome my pleasure thank you for having
me so david your latest book the
american experiment dialogues on a dream
it's an amazing work
um there was a tone of concern in the
book which i would suggest is fairly
appropriate
uh and one of the major challenges you
described in the book was a threat to
our democracy
uh so we're talking right now on the
anniversary of january 6 in the
insurrection how much of this book was
driven by that concern
well there's no doubt that uh the book
was conceived of in the idea that our
democracy is at peril to some extent uh
we have survived 250 years but there's
no guarantee we'll be doing this another
250 years unless we make some changes as
you know from being involved in in
politics uh recently the country is
bitterly divided
and i don't really think that one year
after the events of january 6 were any
closer to coming together in in a in a
compatible way than we were a year ago
so you know everyone under the sun
this book consists largely of interviews
with various historians and thinkers i
agree with you that not much has changed
between last year and this year
in terms of us coming together if you
could wave a magic wand like what what
would you be driving people to do
well i would try to do is to find some
way to um
uh in in effect get people to work in a
bipartisanship kind of manner when i
worked in capitol hill in the late 1970s
and even the white house or president
carter
bipartisanship wasn't a curse word today
if you're seen as bipartisan you're seen
as either not inappropriate to be in the
democratic party or not appropriate to
be in the republican party it's very
difficult to be bipartisan in washington
dc these days so i i it's a sad
situation i i you know i think right now
the country is so bitterly divided that
if the
1964 civil rights act was put on the
floor of the senate i don't think it
could pass today
exactly word for word
unfortunately you're probably right i i
do want to to
give some people a sense of your
background you and i had met a couple of
times
i'm not sure if you remember because i
wasn't famous then a fairly normal
attendee but we met at
out at aspen at the ideas festival a
number of years ago and then at summit
series in los angeles
uh so i consider you to be one of the
most patriotic
uh individuals
in the country
uh based upon
your personal commitments uh you've
actually coined something called
patriotic philanthropy where you
personally restored the washington
monument
thomas jefferson's home the arlington
national cemetery
and i i feel like you did that really
just out of a spirit of service though
it did make me think it's like i feel
like um you know like you're doing
things the government ought to be doing
i took uh the steps that do things
because i don't think the government is
going to do them or do them as quickly
so when the washington monument had its
earthquake damage the head of the park
service told me he thought it might take
two or three years to get the money out
of congress so i decided to do it more
quickly or things that were falling
apart like the lincoln memorial the
jefferson memorial uh these things are
not getting the money they need so i
decided i would put up some money and
help it get it done more quickly the
idea is to remind people the history and
heritage of our country on the theory
that if you know more about the history
and heritage of our country you'll be a
more informed citizen and a more
informed citizenry will make a better
democracy that's the theory so you grew
up
in a modest household the son of a
postal worker in baltimore uh you went
to duke and then the law school you were
an attorney and then you worked in the
carter administration and jamie carter's
been in the news recently
as someone who's deeply concerned about
the progress of our democracy you then
left to co-found uh carlyle group which
is one of the most prominent private
equity firms uh in the world before
private equity was a thing you were kind
of one of the the pioneers
um in that
how close did you ever come to returning
to full out and out public service uh
over the intervening years
well um when i worked in the carter
white house we got inflation to 15 so
there's been no demand for me to come
back in the public service
um secondly as you know firsthand going
into public service today is a great
sacrifice because not only is it a
financial sacrifice which is
insignificant relatively speaking but
it's a personal sacrifice and your
reputation gets ruined people come out
of the woodwork to beat you up for
things that
seem insignificant so if i said i'm
going to go back into public service and
wanted to be confirmed by the senate
somebody will come out of the woodwork
and say that i played spin the bottle
too aggressively when i was in the sixth
grade or something so you just don't
know what's going to happen today and i
just rather than subject myself to
ridiculous criticism i'll just stay on
the sidelines and let younger people and
better people do the kind of public
service work that i used to do the fact
that you become such an avid interviewer
strikes me as fascinating it's like the
equivalent of my showing up to bloomberg
and mike bloomberg interviewing me
um so what what prompted you to head in
this direction because it's been
something you've clearly invested a ton
of time and energy into
um like many things in life it's by
serendipity i suspect 10 years ago you
didn't think you would be a candidate
for president united states or a
candidate for mayor but you happen to
fall into it
i happen to fall into it because vernon
jordan asked me to be the head of the
economic club of washington get speakers
i realized quickly the speakers were
boring and i decided to interview them
and make it a little bit lighter and
people seem to like it and then they put
it on bloomberg tv and other things so i
do enjoy it because i like to ask people
questions
obviously you do too if you wouldn't you
wouldn't have a podcast and
i try to take the best interviews put
them in book form but i guess it stems
back to my intellectual curiosity like
you anybody that's interested in in
doing these kind of podcasts must be
curious about other things so i am
intellectually curious about lots of
things and that helps get it done i also
prepare a lot as you obviously do as
well so it's fun it's i don't play golf
i don't drink alcohol this is my
relaxation
it is fun i agree i enjoy it too because
and in your case you can talk to
uh the most renowned historians uh
global figures um your book the american
experiment includes a number of
fascinating interviews um that there are
a couple of challenges that i i do want
to hone in on maybe because they're what
i'm most acutely
focused on myself
um so one is with an historian named
michael beschloss
who
recounts that what we're dealing with
right now is not normal there have been
contested elections
there have been disputes
but it hasn't risen anywhere near to the
level of today
in part because
there were some norms
and mores that both parties followed
where for example in the book
they talk about when
uh nixon
lost
uh
that there were a number of republicans
who would say yes you know like that
this was a legitimate problem
on
our leader's part
which is
different from the tone of today
and he says that january 6 we almost
didn't make it which i think is
uh something that you and i agree with
uh what
are you seeing
uh in terms of actions on the side of
either one party or the other uh to try
and
help us withstand the next challenge
well we didn't almost succeed uh the way
we did in january six because had it it
had their situation changed a little bit
uh the the election would have gone to
donald trump and this is what i mean we
now it's now public information that
there was a plan to take it to the house
of representatives if you could get the
senate not to certify and it would go to
the house the house had more republican
delegations than democratic delegations
and you vote by delegation so that would
have produced a
a trump victory uh we were lucky to
dodge that bullet when you think back on
it in your lifetime in my lifetime we've
lived through something similar and that
was the election of 2000 when george w
bush won by maybe 534 votes in florida
i suspect if donald trump had lost by
534 votes in florida he would not have
done what al gore did just give a nice
concession speech and go about his way
so it's amazing that al gore was willing
to go away the way he did uh when you
consider how close that election was and
really there may have well have been
some fraud in some parts of florida
certainly more than we saw in the in the
most recent election in my view at least
yeah i agree that was an act of uh
patriotism on al gore's part i think a
lot of people on his shoes would have uh
persisted litigated um set the the
country into something of a protracted
um struggle and certainly no one can
imagine donald trump walking away with a
vote margin that small i mean even
though he in my view lost very cleanly
uh this time albeit by tens of thousands
of votes spread out over three states
um
the fear is that he's going to challenge
the outcome this time um again and come
back
my read is that he's the most likely
republican party nominee um and should
be considered a serious
threat to win re-election outright in
2024 uh would you agree with that as
like a a tentative forecast as we're
having this conversation
you know the day after the election uh
last year i i went on television and
said on squawk box i think he'll run
again people laughed at me at the time i
do think he is considering running again
and if he thinks he can win he will run
again and i i wouldn't rule out his
winning again it went you know he he won
once and i wouldn't rule out his winning
again um because right now um
you know the popularity that he has has
not receded it has actually if anything
among his supporters gotten stronger
and so in the last year he has done a
pretty good job of keeping himself alive
even though he's not on twitter not on
facebook
he seems to have a following that's
fairly intense and as you know in
politics the trick is getting your votes
out and he can probably get his votes
out so i would say if the election were
held today for example i think he'd have
a pretty good chance of winning yeah i
agree
and even if he were to come close uh he
would proclaim victory and and you'd
wind up with protests and civil
unrest and perhaps violence
around the country which is a scenario
that i think the country should be
seriously preparing for
[Music]
all right guys it's 2022 how is your
mental health what is preventing you
from achieving your goals how's your
stress is there anything interfering
with your happiness folks i want you to
check out
yang because at betterhelp.com
you can assess your needs and match with
a licensed professional therapist so
it's not like a crisis line is a secure
safe and private online professional
counseling environment it's super
convenient you can start communicating
in under 48 hours you just get matched
on there super simple again you can
basically just send a message to your
counselor anytime so that's texting
little chats or you can do video
conferences which i would do once a week
and you get timely thoughtful responses
plus you can schedule weekly pho in our
video sessions it's pretty freaking
great so whether you've got depression
stress anxiety relationship issues
sleeping trouble anger family conflicts
grief you name it
anything you share is confidential and a
licensed professional can help you and
guide you through this securely online
convenient professional affordable i
want you to check out better help so
here's the deal
andrew and i want you to start living a
happier life today and as a listener
you're going to get 10 off your first
month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com yang join over 1 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health again that's
betterhelphelp.com
[Music]
so recently dave and i and i don't know
if you've been keeping up with anything
i've been doing it's totally cool if you
have not
uh that i i've come to the conclusion
that one of the reasons why we're so
concerned about donald trump uh and
the threat to democracy is that we have
something of a fragile system in the
form of duopoly
and you talk about the 13
dna strands or genes for american
success number one for you is democracy
which i'd agree with number two is
voting i'd also agree with
there are various anti-lower case d
democratic elements to our current
system
where for example 83 percent of the
congressional races in the country
are
determined in the primary because
they've been gerrymandered as a safe
seat either democratic or republican so
you have a lot of americans who are
checked out of politics because it's
sort of a for ordained conclusion which
party is going to win
uh 10 to 15 percent of americans are
effectively electing you know 83 percent
of representatives going up to 90
and so that there's nothing
um in the constitution about the number
of parties uh the founding documents
seem to suggest that our founders didn't
like parties and that if they were to
have parties they would certainly want
more than two
um i see you as someone who uh i
associate you with the democratic party
because you worked at the carter
administration do you think that one of
the issues
that's making us more susceptible to
a rise of authoritarianism is the
two-party system itself
i'm not sure i would agree with that
only for this reason one we have
stability in this country which is
relatively important virtue
um in the weimar republic there were
many different uh
uh parties and it's you know obviously
what happened in the in the nazi germany
didn't come about because there were
only two parties there there were
multiple parties there uh the israeli
government has multiple parties and it's
hard to say that's a well-run government
because one vote here or there can
destabilize the entire government so i'm
not sure that the two-party system is as
bad as that has been over the last
couple years clearly uh it can be
improved but if you have instability is
that going to be better off for the
country i don't know and i think you do
have more instability when you have more
parties now it's not to say that these
are the only two parties if you were to
start as i think you are a third party
and it takes off it could replace
with some of the other parties remember
we had the whig party we had many other
parties it wasn't the democratic and
republican party at the beginning of our
country and they evolved over a period
of time but i think it's difficult to
build a political party right now uh
given the wealth that's required to do
so
oh you you're a registered independent
it sounds like i have joined you as a
registered independent over the last
three months i have to say it's been a
great three months
i i do think that now that i've taken
off my democratic hat i genuinely do see
things uh differently and it turns out
that
self-identified independents do
outnumber democrats and republicans very
significantly the the is around 44
percent independent maybe 28 democrat
and 23 percent republican
so the challenge really is to
have a party that independents uh feel
can compete and contend uh and want to
join that is what i'm working on right
now uh the the forward party not left or
right but forward the issue is that the
mechanics of our elections make a third
party competing very very difficult uh
if not impossible because they've been
set up in a certain way where with a
closed party primary you need to be
essentially a republican or democrat to
compete in that primary to have a chance
to win so what we're advocating for
are non-partisan open primaries so you
can vote for anyone of any party
combined with ranked choice voting so
there's no spoiler effect
and people can express their preferences
you can vote for a third party first and
then you know a major party
second and not worry about wasting your
vote i don't know if you spend any time
looking at these reforms or if they're
they're things that you think might help
alleviate the extremism because at least
uh in practice they should reward
moderates and people that appeal to a
broader part of the population
well look there are lots of different
ways you can experiment but until you
take money out of politics i don't think
you're going to make the big changes you
really want right now money is so
important to the way the political
system works that i i think it's
corrupting in any ways i don't make
political contributions because i just
think it just
is it's not appropriate for me to be
doing that but i i just don't uh think
until you take money out of politics any
of these reforms are going to be able to
eliminate the left or the right because
so many people in the far left or the
far right can raise money by appealing
to people on the far left in the far
right and and why are they appealing
they're appealing because they make they
can raise money doing this and and money
is very important why do members of
congress raise so much money why do you
think that is it's not because they need
it you just pointed out 83 percent of
the people can get re-elected in the
house why do they need that much money
they want the money because one if you
have a big pot of money you can scare
people from running against you two you
can give it to other members to get
leadership positions and three you can
keep the money after you leave office
i i agree with you that you would need
money uh to have more political figures
accept or even embrace a third party
what i've been telling people david is
that politicians run on three things
money
media and votes
i i just amazing to me how many members
of congress really are happy when they
leave the place and um it's sad that
they feel they have to keep raising all
this money to stay in office but it's
it's the system we have it's not going
to change in your case look
you can be a person who might change the
country you're a young person so you
have 20 or 30 years of vitality where
you can go ahead and maybe make this
difference and your question is the
question for you is do you want to
devote your life to this or do you want
to do other things because if you spend
all your time on this you might not make
a lot of progress you just don't know a
lot of people have tried this before and
have not gotten them very far
oh i know david uh you know i was joking
with someone where people talked about
my third party
uh efforts as somehow
a path to glory or self angry and
diceman and i laughed i was like this is
the wilderness
you know it's not like not like i'm
unmindful of the fact that people who've
gone down this road uh have run into
massive challenges why don't you
consider why don't you run for congress
you you could run for congress and get
elected why don't you do that if i were
a member of congress today i think i
would feel very frustrated um because
uh the incentives are what you're
describing um i wouldn't be able to get
that much done um i would end up raising
money to feather my own nest uh and the
system would continue to grind on in a
way that would keep us polarized
the only way we can alleviate this
extreme polarization that we're seeing
is to change the two-party dynamic in my
opinion but if you go back over the last
50 years or so and look at third-party
efforts to really build a third party
they haven't really gotten very far
ralph nader tried it um john anderson
tried it uh many other people tried it
and it just it's very difficult to do
bill weld tried it it's just very
difficult to do and you know you have to
say you have a finite number of hours on
the face of the earth what are you going
to do with those finite hours but it's
uh i didn't have people you know
shooting at me if i you know if i failed
in other words right now people you make
people if i didn't my firm didn't
succeed the world wasn't going to fall
apart and people weren't going to
criticize me all that much you're going
to have people targeting you all the
time now because they're going to say
you're trying to ruin the system or
you're you obviously need to have a
thick skin if you're able to do this
thicker than mine
thank you for noticing
[Music]
it's 2022 folks and if you are a small
business owner like we are you are busy
enough as it is you don't have time to
deal with the hassle of going to the
post office and i want to talk to you
about stamps.com because with stamps.com
you can skip the trip never waste
another dollar or minute stamps.com lets
you print official postage right from
your computer so you can spend less time
at the post office and more time doing
the thing you're supposed to be doing
like you know running your business so
stamps.com saves you time money and
stress for more than 20 years stamps.com
has been indispensable for over 1
million businesses including ours they
give you access to all the post office
and ups shipping services you need right
from your computer so whether you're
sending invoices you got your side
hustle etsy shop or you're like a
full-blown warehouse shipping out
hundreds of orders stamps.com will make
your life easier and all you need is a
computer with a standard printer no
special supplies or equipment it's
pretty freaking easy you're up and
running in minutes printing official
postage for any letter any package
anywhere you want to send so here's the
deal save money and time this year with
stamps.com sign up with promo code yang
for a special offer that includes a four
week trial free postage and a digital
scale no long term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com folks we
love this stuff click the microphone at
the top of the page enter code yang get
your four week trial right now
i agree with you that money is corrupted
politics um i think citizens united was
a terrible ruling it made a bad
situation worse
um i have a proposal that i think would
help so certainly i'm for overturning
citizens united but practically that's
next to impossible because it would
require
a super majority possibly even a
constitutional amendment well if you had
a constitutional amendment that would uh
limit the amount of money that could be
put in the campaigns
and you could limit the amount of time
people spent campaigning it would make
progress but it's not likely to happen
in singapore for example
the prime minister when i talked to him
last time he said
he just campaigned and how how long was
your campaign four days the campaign for
prime minister or the the parliament was
about four days maybe it was a week um
our campaigns are basically
never ending right
and the amount of money is extraordinary
that's spent in it and as you probably
know from your own experience
where does most of the money go
a large part of it goes to media and
it's a it's an incredible uh you know
sinkhole advertising and media social
media is where the money mostly goes now
yeah it's even more of a sinkhole when
you think about the fact that billions
are spent in opposition to each other
essentially canceling each other out i
mean
if the rnc and the dnc were to just
jointly look at each other and say hey
i'll take a billion you take a billion
and maybe we
uh fix some roads
or do something that they could benefit
from so i don't i don't know how much
now in the in the most world most parts
of the campaign world you would know
this as a candidate people volunteer
and people
work for very low wages but in the media
buying part and the advertising part of
part of campaigns the people that
actually buy it they get a percentage of
the revenue that you're spending
and that's an incredible incentive for
people to get in in the business of of
getting people like you to spend more
money on advertising because they're
getting a percentage of the revenue
oh yeah when i was running for president
david as soon as we started raising
serious money the consultants came in
and said hey you need to buy tv ads
and we get this percent and i looked at
it and said what a racket um but did we
end up spending those millions of
dollars on those tv ads yes we did
so
you're not wrong well it happens because
uh they have an incentive because it's
the only part of campaigns where people
actually make a profit because they're
getting a percentage of the revenue it
used to be i in the early days of
politics used to be ten percent i think
it's been squeezed down to two or three
percent now or something like that but
still if you put out more money they get
a bigger percentage so that just fuels
people keep buying more and more ads
yes
so
on this
this crisis in democracy it sounds like
your main calls
are to
improve the climate of bipartisanship in
congress which is very difficult and
right now it's getting worse
it's very difficult my view is i'm
trying to spend time on education
educating people about civics and
history we're way behind there you can't
do everything one of the things i'm
focused on is getting people to know
more about our history our civics how
our government works and the theory that
maybe that'll lead to a more informed
democracy
the other major challenge i wanted to
talk to you about
is with the economy and capitalism
carlisle invests around the world so you
have a sense about how america is faring
relative to other countries there was
a really interesting interview you had
with an author named abu srinivasan who
wrote about the history of capitalism in
america over a 400 year period
you cite capitalism and entrepreneurship
as one of the vital
american strands of dna which i
happen to agree with you've also
probably seen the attitude towards
capitalism
uh darken and sour over the last number
of years here in america
boo describes capitalism i love this
description
as an operating system that requires
adjustments updates patches safeguards
and constant iteration to work properly
i thought that was the most apt
description of capitalism i'd seen in
quite some time in your view
how is our operating system doing
well if you're wealthy it's doing
extremely well
if you're educated uh you're doing
probably reasonably well if you're
uneducated you work with your hands you
are living paycheck to paycheck um you
don't have child care you don't have
access to the internet uh you're not
it's not doing very well so what's
happened in as a result of covid is that
the gap between the wealthy and the
non-wealthy has gotten greater
and that gap is not likely to close
anytime soon so capitalism works well
for people at the top it works really
well for people in the middle it's awful
for people at the very bottom right now
those at the bottom i think are doing
worse than they were two years ago yeah
so to the extent that he describes this
set of adjustments updates patches
safeguards uh
that capitalism requires
uh do you have a few that you would like
to see adopted well i think capitalism
right now the way western capitalism
works is basically we've concluded we
let entrepreneurs pretty much do what
they want with modest regulation and we
we think that businesses that are
created are going to likely do better
things for society than than than not
having a uh free entrepreneurial system
however we have a reasonably good social
net not as good as europe not as good as
some other countries our social net has
failed in some places in this country if
you as you know the european system
which i'm not saying is perfect they do
have a bigger and better social net than
we do for people at the bottom and what
we have in this problem and you you
would recognize this to some extent as
well
um what we have in this system is a uh
we have a belief in the american dream
by and large it turns out that many
people now in this country born here
people who are of racial minorities uh
particularly african-americans don't
believe in the american dream so much
they think the american dream is
basically hogwash and it's people who
come from other countries we have 47
million immigrants in this country they
believe in the american dream more
ironically than people are born here and
it's because the people at the very
bottom are not doing well if you go in
the inner cities of any major city in
the united states you live in new york
you go in the worst parts of new york
city what you see is hard to believe
that this is a wealthy country you see
you know people living in poverty people
and look at the homelessness in new york
or my city washington dc a staggering
amount of homelessness it's hard to say
that capitalism is working well right
yeah i i definitely have been in those
neighborhoods and came away stunned uh
and shocked by
the circumstances that a lot of people
are living in particularly uh people of
color black and brown people in new york
city
[Music]
you and i again admit a couple of times
and i would not fault you at all if you
don't recall because i was one of many
uh
and then i made the national stage
running for president as a democratic
candidate uh proposing universal basic
income which is actually an idea that
you recognized i'm sure from the 60s and
70s because it was more
it was more thoroughly
uh contemplated at that point when you
saw my presidential campaign what was
your reaction when you're like oh good
this idea is back or like
or was it a different reaction well i
would say uh that idea has been around
before
and in effect we have it to some extent
now because people at the bottom of the
economic strata they're not paying
federal income taxes
and they're really not paying social
security taxes that much or there's a
rebate but it's not enough it's not
adequate i'm not saying it's enough but
i would say that i'm giving people
something in the way that you proposed
it
raises the hackles that that nixon did
when he looked nixon proposed that
patton moynihan proposed it to nixon and
nixon went along with it nixon amazingly
supported it for a while until he
realized it was not something his
constituency liked so much i would say
it's it's
it's an easy to criticize it's easier to
do it through the tax system than giving
people grants but
um i would say we we have some of what
you propose already um and that build
back better legislation if it ever
passed as an initial form would have
done more of that
but trying to give people money in the
appropriation sense and with more
entitlements is much more difficult
these days uh yeah the enhanced child
tax credit was in some ways
reminiscent of the the moynihan nixon
plan um and 442 economists have endorsed
making it permanent um in part because
it's it's pulled several million kids
out of poverty which i i suspect are you
a fan of the the child tax credit i
imagine you are
um i i think it's it's good it's not
going to solve our problems uh it's it's
fine i i do think that we should though
do something that you you may or may not
be in favor of uh when the budget act of
1974 was passed it was passed in order
to make sure that we actually kept our
budget more or less in in kind of
balance to some extent or at least we
knew what we're spending uh now the
budget the budget deficit at the time
the united states was under 500 billion
dollars now it's 29 trillion
so how do we have a budget act of 74 and
go from 500 billion of debt to 29
trillion well the answer is among other
things a lot of budget games and the
most common one was pointed out in the
building back better
legislation right now we have 10-year
budgeting uh no company runs on 10-year
budgeting so what we do is we we pass
legislation and then we we say we're
gonna get the cost of it back in years
eight nine and ten but it never actually
comes back and then so you just increase
these deficits so i wish we would uh
have more honest budgeting and and just
know what we're spending money on but
look right now the budget of the united
states is really about six and a half
trillion dollars
almost half of that a year or so ago was
borrowed
we're borrowing about a third of our
budget every year that's not sustainable
so something's got to give and you can
only do this in one way you either
default on your debt which is not going
to work you have to increase taxes which
is not popular you cut spending which is
not popular you have income you can have
economic growth that's greater than it
is or you inflate your way out of it and
i'm afraid we're heading in the
inflating our way out of it problem
a solution i should say uh it seems like
right now
uh in my view inflation
is
going to be an issue
for the next number of months there's
going to be pressure on the fed to raise
rates
if the fed does raise rates you'd
imagine there'd be a significant market
correction
like how do you see the situation
playing out
if there was an easy answer i would have
been in new hampshire with you or in in
iowa with you uh there's no easy answer
obviously um i think the the most likely
scenario is that we're going to increase
taxes on wealthy people but that is not
enough wealthy people you got to
increase tax on the middle class and
that's tough to do because the wealth is
really in the middle class and there
aren't enough really health very wealthy
people to solve all your problems um
secondly you're going to inflate your
way out of this problem to some extent
and third you're going to basically see
a devaluation of the dollar those seem
to be the paths out and none of them are
good um so it's true it's too bad you
weren't with me in iowa and new
hampshire that would have been fun david
i don't think they had a lot of private
equity people in the democratic
primaries i have noticed that but if you
if you stay in your current party you
wouldn't be able to be in the in the
debates and so forth right so ross perot
ran for president and got 19.3 percent
of the vote in 92
a time that was probably more trusting
and pro-institution than it is now and
his and he at one point briefly
suspended his campaign so if he hadn't
done that he probably would have
gone higher
my friend mark cuban pulled himself in
2020
just to see how he would do um had
himself at 25 percent
uh independents right now are at 45 to
50 percent 62 percent of americans want
to move on from the duopoly if you had a
credible third party candidate and the
field was let's say joe biden and donald
trump combined age 159
about in 2024
i think a third party candidate walks
around with 15 to 20 percent but let's
suppose your premise is true
you would have to get somebody that i
think americans really think is a great
hero or an extraordinary person
uh and maybe you but it needs to be
somebody that i think is somebody really
people would really admire for what he
or she has already achieved i agree uh
and one of my projects of this time is
trying to identify who that candidate
might be
which is a really fun project
[Music]
uh so in this history of capitalism that
uh
that bus renovassan recounts he talked
about one of the most dramatic episodes
being
henry ford's elevated salary for model t
manufacturing workers
where it made headline news it was
essentially double
the customary salary
and it would enable
a worker the average worker to be able
to buy the model t
uh
based on three months of income and so
this was a game changer
and i was trying to imagine what a
modern day equivalent of that would be
like it would be something like i i
guess like what is the the fort of today
uh maybe it's amazon and maybe amazon
wakes up tomorrow jeff bezos they
actually have the money to do this so
this would be a fascinating exercise uh
it would be like if they woke up
tomorrow and said hey everyone gets paid
30 bucks an hour like like twice a
minute wage
uh
now i think most people look back fondly
on
the
model t manufacturing wage being higher
they see that as something of an emblem
of the progression of capitalism of
american industry do you think that's
right uh and do you think that it's
possible that something like that could
happen today i don't i feel like it
couldn't um but if it did happen would
it be desirable
well it wouldn't maybe you could argue
have some inflationary impact i wouldn't
worry about that if amazon or apple or
other people said look we're going to
make sure that all our employees get
paid uh i don't know 25 an hour or
whatever some higher than minimum wage
is uh that might be beneficial it would
set a trend off for the country it might
be inflationary so it's hard to know
right now it's hard to believe though
but the minimum wage united states is
still about seven and a half dollars an
hour yeah even 15 is an effective
doubling in 15 was but that was over
four years uh that that going to 15 and
that was the proposal so it's amazing
that the minimum wage is still so low uh
as it is um i i i don't know whether
there's an entrepreneur today who is
willing to do the kind of things that
henry ford did
i hope so but there's a limited number
of individuals who are able to do it to
do that
you have this this global perspective
this is something i was uh i was eager
to ask you about based upon something
that also that
um that business on said
he was trying to compare the chinese
model capitalism to the american model
and he said something that would make a
lot of americans i think fall out of
their chair he said the communists seem
to be very good at capitalism
and he talked about an example of
thousand dollar drones that china is
able to manufacture with ease we've seen
it now even with some of the drugs and
testing
where a lot of that stuff is
manufactured overseas in america
and he says that the bulk of our
economic policy is determined by the
consumer market which is a mistake and
you should have some policy that's
uh that's directed towards things other
than low prices
and what consumers want
you guys invest everywhere carlile just
tries to find great opportunities and
firms how optimistic are you about the
american model of capitalism relative to
let's say the chinese okay look the
american model of capitalism has
obviously worked for a couple hundred
years and done quite well the chinese
model is different and it's got some
improvements over ours and has some
deficiencies
there's a new book out by somebody you
probably know
um and ray dalio called the changing
world order
and in it he basically says that the
chinese motto of capitalism probably
will prevail
over the next
50 years or so over the american model
because china is a rising power and its
form of capitalism probably will
ultimately be uh more successful than
ours and that's that's a short-circuit
way of saying what he said but
essentially the american model is going
down a bit because we borrowed too much
money
we're not as hard working maybe as we
used to be all the things you probably
know about and so i think the chinese
model shouldn't be dismissed by
americans as as ridiculous it wouldn't
suit our our freedom our interest in
freedom but the chinese motto of
communism or capitalism does have some
benefits that has made their economy you
know
basically the biggest in the world
so given your
uh
conversations with everyone under the
sun in our nation's capital i probably
should dig into your dinners with
members of congress more deeply because
they sound fascinating uh
i feel like you started out
your trilogy of books
um kind of uh
a bit more optimistic
[Laughter]
it seems like the concern level has
risen it could just be because the order
of the interviews as presented look
anybody that's an entrepreneur and
you've been an entrepreneur by
definition is somewhat optimistic
because if you are pessimistic you would
just get in a hole you wouldn't do
anything so by nature i'm optimistic but
i'm also realistic that we have some
challenges in this country there are
challenges that people of my economic
background are not going to be suffering
from as much as people who are lower in
the economic totem pole
so um it's not a perfect system but i
you know i'm now at an age i'm much
older than you where i'm trying to get
things done
in my lifetime and i'm not trying to do
things that i think aren't going to get
done in my lifetime so i'm working on
different things and you you your
project is going to take 10 20 30 years
to get maybe having a
fruition and you might be successful in
30 years i don't have 30 years to give
to something so i'm trying to do
different things
well that's one thing i admire about you
uh that you're trying to get it done
quickly um so if there is something that
you would want
our listeners uh to
dig into
to maybe
check out volunteer contribute uh like
what are ways that people can get
engaged try to do something
to make your neighborhood your city your
country something better than it was
before just don't you don't have to be
you know solving all the problems of the
world or you don't have to be securing
cancer just find something you can
contribute to and you'll feel better
about yourself and you'll probably live
longer because you'll feel better about
yourself secondly read more about what's
going on in the world and read books
focus the brain better than internet uh
you know memos or something like that
read books
read more
um and try to figure out how you can
contribute to your society and therefore
think what you can do to make the world
a slightly better place in your 80 or 90
years on the surface of this earth
because we're here a relatively short
period of time
david i love the fact that you're trying
to get it done uh in your lifetime you
have more resources than just about any
of us
i hope you live a very long and fruitful
life and the rest of it uh but when we
do revisit you and your legacy like what
do you hope it is
well um as you would probably know most
people would say if you and you have
children as well you want to have
children who are successful
and are healthy and happy so that's one
of the great legacies
secondly uh you want to make people feel
that you've done something useful with
your time on the face of the earth and
so that's another one
try to do something useful while you're
here um you know you feel like you've
done something useful by getting
involved in campaigns and it may be that
you can change the whole political
system if you're successful i suspect
it's going to take you 15 or 20 years
before you realize whether you're making
it or not
well i i agree but i'm actually pushing
you to ask you like how are you going to
measure your own progress because you
have more in the way of resources it
sounds like you're investing in civics
education is there like a like a goal
you've set for yourself well my goals
and my philanthropic goals are to start
something that wouldn't otherwise get
started finish something that wouldn't
otherwise get finished um do something
that
i'm intellectually interested in so i'll
stay involved in it not just write a
check and fourth i see some progress in
my lifetime and so i pick projects that
do that but the most important one of
all is educating people so most of my
money goes to education and
scholarships i mean the things that
we've talked about patriotic
philanthropy is five percent of my net
my net giving 95 is in medical research
and education well that's going to be a
phenomenal legacy david thank you so
much for sharing your work with us
uh this book is a phenomenal achievement
the american experiment dialogues on a
dream uh let's get people reading more
books thank you and next one i'll have
you in it okay i that's a promise thank
you david
[Music]
you